[Music]
it's gonna be so good
rent I don't know about this man alright
guys I've finally done it I've built the
world's largest laser gun rent what if
you miss don't miss lasers go straight
here plucked about an aimer on there
whoa whoa why is it going so slow though
Oh bigger things have more gravity and
that slows down time ran that's not how
it works if you had just water go save
your cards for your pop where my keys
are you oh my god
guys we do you stop this laser
thankfully it's going really slow and
that gives it's time to figure this out
how much time how long is it gonna take
an hour okay I think we can probably
have this figured out in an hour
hi everyone sorry we bother
there's a giant deadly laser coming this
way so please watch out
[Music]
the laser right now
all the way you're under arrest for
murder
turn around put your hands out dry your
weapon
a machine thought shot right out of
solution you're under arrest
right to remain silent anything you do
or say
I think we're safe I think we're good
hey you're definitely still under arrest
this is ridiculous well here's your
personal these are my personals these
are the items we have Friday stay on the
card our store check this out whoa and
look at this we took that same design
and put on a bobsleigh shirt that's
pretty neat if you're cold don't worry
we've got you covered with this nice
quarter digital beanie long days ahead
we have a special portal trickshots
t-shirt directed this one classic and if
you spend more than $60 you'll get a
custom pin with a back card signed by
the whole crew a quarter but now the
prison
seventy-five dollars we'll even get free
shipping in the US now that I've got
some freedom where should I go
I think he's gonna head on down over to
corridor digital that store